It fills you with,
see the scene when you look at the sun
and the moon is that which is beyond,
you
communicate with what's a small rise and
so you offer something to the absolute
and it get a sense of the quality
of your offering as a consequence of
[inaudible].
Like I said,
it's an archaic idea you can run as child,
child,
child life.
So you communicate with
you talking sacrifice.
Katie sacrifices his offerings.
He will sacrifice his kids
then because we're taking
these three series,
okay,
what's going on?
Well here's what's going on and this is
how finding 12 rules for like as well.
It's all about 20 years to figure out.
What about this idea of sacrifice?
What the Hell's behind that?
Cause it's a human universal right here.
I'm sacrificial bone tt.
Everyone.
We were,
well you can think,
you can think it through.
If you think about how people use
the word sacrifice in Monday morning,
who I teach,
my students have university
with Royal Children's,
first generation immigrants.
So they're,
you know,
their parents sacrificed the law in
order to give them an opportunity.
So what did they sacrifice?
But they offer the sacrifice
to their home country.
Sometimes they sacrifice a prevention
because maybe they were doctors where they
came from.
The couldn't get licensed in Canada,
so they ended up running
a convenience store,
laundry or something like that.
Working,
you know,
publishing house of their
kids have an opportunity.
So if you ask the kids,
well what did your parents sacrificing
that you could go to university?
It's like their hands are not going away.
I understand that language.
And then you can ask them too.
Well,
what do you sacrifice for your grades?
I don't party every night
before go ratification.
So what does it mean?
I sacrificed something that though
you'd need to make the future better.
I'm acting out the proposition that I can
borrow phage by giving them something.
Now I can make something
better in the future.
Think that is an absolutely
overwhelming discovery.
That's what human beings discovered
is it's so strange because it works.
You can read if I'm putting through the
value in the present and it does pay off
in the future.
Now that's partly because
you're bargaining with
future people and they're not
going to encourage you that you can read
more about how the 12 rules for life if
you want.
The point is that it wasn't archaic at
the ritual was Sikh people were acting up
something they didn't understand.
They've watched how people
that were successful were
successful and they watched
people how people who weren't
successful one and they extract it out.
This idea that the people who were
successful were doing something that made
them successful and it was like sacrifice.
And so they ritualizing sacrifices
have you understand what it was.
And eventually that became
a psychological concept,
which was,
well,
you can give,
you know,
you do have,
you have to renew yourself
and the new year's fest,
by the way,
which is an unbelievably old idea,
you give up your pathological
past self and you make some,
um,
when you call goals resolution,
a real issue,
it's about how you can
be new in the future.
And that was a sacrificial act.
And it's based on a very
old ritual that has roots,
at least in Mesopotamia at least
5,000 years ago where the king handed.
I do that every new year so that he can
be a good king for the upcoming year,
which you can also read about that.
It maps.
Maybe you want to read about that.
Interesting.
Anyways,
the whole idea is that
this whole sacrifice thing,
this actually works and they're not.
That brings up a whole realm of Preston.
It's like,
well,
the sacrifices works.
What's the best possible sacrifice,
right?
Because that's obviously when you figured
out that at work you want to figure
out what would optimize it and part of
that is you have to sacrifice that what
you love and that's part
of the active labor.
When Abraham is called on to sacrifice,
I say,
I can see versions of that idea.
Maybe what you love most as a person
you love the most and you think,
what does that mean?
You said you offer your son up to God.
What you mean when you ask the
question because the answer,
that kind of stuff is actually yes.
In fact,
that's exactly what you do if you're an
ideal parent because you want your son
or your daughter to be as
good as they can possibly be,
let's say,
making the sacrifices that are necessary
in order to carry them through life.
So even though the idea again is part
Berrington are archaic and its ritual
form,
there's the siege in that
manner of incalculable.
Brilliant.
In any case,
God's happy with able to sacrifices and
he's not happy with Katie suffices and
there's reality and there's not
exactly what the swipe of the story,
it's kind of thing.
Not Exactly.
It's huge,
but it's big and that's good
because you know you don't look,
life is like you're doing
everything you can to sick yourself.
Right?
I could put the world in order
around and it isn't working.
There's sacrifices are being rejected.
What's the consequences of that?
Well,
if you're not trying,
when you fail,
well it sucks because it's not very
exciting not to try and who the hell wants
to fail,
but at least you're not punish
you for your best efforts.
But if you made your sacrifices
and they're rejected,
then what's the right attitude towards
up volcanoes out is to get bigger.
He gets fitter because April is,
you're taking these sacrifices.
It works like mad now thrilled about Amy.
He's popular with forks increase,
everybody likes him worse.
He's the sort of guy who deserves it.
And that's super annoying,
right?
Because there's nothing more annoying
and coming to meet someone hyper
successful and then also
realizing that they deserve it.
You think that person would have to have
good graces to be contemptible so you
wouldn't have to be envious about the
fact that everything is going well for
them.
But often that doesn't work out.
So [inaudible] you raged by nick spice,
continual failure and he's outraged at
April because April's successes casting
to stay there and even a more dim
light and he's burning about the,
um,
the justice,
the injustice in the world.
And so he decides to call out
God because how to get it,
why not chain?
And so he has the little chocolates
God and says something along the lines.
I've cried a lot of different
translations of this interchange.
Just good to what was at the bottom of it.
It's quite complicated,
but basically what happens is Katie
calls out God the creator of reality.
He says something like,
what the hell is up here?
I'm breaking myself in half
trying to have a half decent life.
Everything I do,
just it's turns to ash and then there's
my brother whose doesn't seem to be
making sacrifices or any
more heartfelt than me.
He's a spectacular success.
It's like,
what the hell is going on?
Kinda crazy planet is this anyway,
so that you've created where this
sort of thing is so likely to happen,
but you know you might first of all
told to that the probability that you
thought that way in your life
from time to time is 100% in fact,
I suspect that there's a substantial
number of you in the room who think like
that almost all the time.
It's extraordinary tempting because
when things fall apart for you,
which they do from time to time,
it's like,
well,
who doesn't want to go onsite and shake
his fist at the sky and rail against the
horror of running fig?
Right?
The question arises like how can the
rule be constituted in such an unjust
manner and who's to blame?
You might say,
well,
I don't believe in God,
it's him.
It's irrelevant.
It doesn't matter from the psychological
perspective it happens anyways.
You act it out anyways.
Also God listens but he's not,
you know,
taking responsibility because,
because he thinks it's king fall and so
this is what he tells cake essentially.
He says it's a very
interesting use of language.
He says sin coaches since by the way,
that we're needs to draw your
Arrow back and to miss the target.
It's a very particular kind of word.
It needs to miss what you're in
rehab or perhaps not aiming at all.
So it applies that perhaps Ramey,
Amy wrong if you don't get the target
right and you specify the targets.
And that's an interesting
part of that as well.
So is it the case sin
crouches at your door?
Like that predatory sexually aroused cap,
you have been invited into your life,
you've opened the door to it and you
voluntarily had your way with it.
And it being that in a sexual manner,
sort of like the old idea that a vampire
can't come into your house on us,
you would find it in.
So first of all,
he tells Kane,
don't be so sure that it's the structure
of reality that's at fault here.
Maybe it's something that you're either
doing or not doing and he accuses of
directing says not only
are you not giving it,
you're also doing it.
There's something there
that tiller king gets.
No,
I'm good.
You've asked him to come in.
No way have you asked him to command.
You've made it with it in a creative
manner and you've given birth to something
horrible as a consequence
and have know it.
And so that's what happens
with the mess with God.
You find out things that
you don't want to find out.
And so painting was not very happy
when he started this discussion.
And when he's done with the discussion,
he's seriously not happy.
And the story says his countenance fail,
which means that he was
enraged by that answer.
And no wonder because he's got
the problem that he had before,
which is that everything's
going to hell around him.
And his brother was a
thriving plus go on himself,
just told him that it's completely his
fault and that he knows he's doing it.
And then he chose to do it.
Well,
what's,
what are you going to do
in a situation like that?
Well,
you do what people do.
You take a rock and you
killed your brother,
right?
And that's what happens.
And that's,
and it's a horrifying story because
it's really the first story about the,
and it's a story of an annuity
and hatred and murder and worse,
because what happens then is Katie is
spared by God for complex reasons that we
won't get into.
And then he goes out and has a
family and he has his descendants.
And what is the sentence is tubal cave.
And [inaudible] is the first
person who makes weapons of war.
So there's this idea that the corruption
of the individual that was represented
by Kane is part of the process.
So there's more to that.
So if you,
if you,
it's so pain,
let's say kills you if you and so child
and [inaudible] child til seven of you
and if you insult Keynes,
Graham Charlatan,
he kills 49 to two.
So there's this idea that this corrupt
process that came part took him,
expands exponentially.
I'll do to the community page.
Potential descendant is to
locate who makes weapons war,
right?
So does this direct blind Henry story
between the Pauling vengeful nature of
cane and his jealousy and spite and
refusal to take responsibility for the of
his actions and inactions murder and
genocide and it's all in like one
paragraph.
It's absolutely overwhelming.
Back to the high school she would use,
they're just acting out
exactly the same old story.
It's the same thing over and over.
That's why these stories are typical.
It's why we can never forget them and
they always happen and hopefully we can
come to understanding.
I'm just going to have some possibility
of avoiding the worst of the
catastrophes.
High school shooters,
people like to call them my kids.
They wrote down what they did know
as far as they were concerned.
They were rejected at least in part.
And you know,
people make much of that same well the
poor kids who were bullied and that's
what they do for vantage.
It's like first of all and
working stuff that kids,
second of all,
most people are voting and they don't
feel want to blog to high school and it
wasn't just that they call them.
My kids wanted to go in there and kill.
That was only a tiny fraction of what
they were planning in their fantasies.
They wanted to take out the whole city,
the entire city.
They have propane bones plans.
They wanted to make a media spectacle
it management quick attractively.
They wanted to produce as much mayhem
as they possibly could in the shortest
possible period of time and cap it off
their own suicide just to demonstrate how
little they character the damn world.
And that's the motivation
behind that sort of thing.
It's a deep and dark motivation.